NARRATOR: How much would
it cost to be a wizard
at Hogwarts like Harry Potter?
Let's find out.
You just got your acceptance letter
to Hogwarts
and you're extremely excited,
but you need to get the checkbook out
because it's going to pricey.
If you're a true Potterhead, you know
that J.K. Rowling has declared that
Hogwarts tuition is free because the
Ministry of Magic covers the costs,
so the seven years you'll spend
studying at Hogwarts will be
completely free, unlike my education.
Hogwarts tuition $0.
You're going to need to get
some wizard school supplies
and there's no better place than
the theme park gift shop.
I mean Diagon Alley.
According to the Hogwarts
acceptance letter,
students are required to buy
many things ranging from
a winter cloak to a pewter cauldron.
These items cost $1,031.
Do you want a magical pet?
Most bird breeders will charge
about $250 for an owl adoption.
Add on some veterinarian costs, food,
a nice cage,
we get to $400.
But how about transportation?
Go to platform nine
and three-quarters
and board the Hogwarts express.
The average train ride
going that distance in England
is about $150.
Now that you're living in Hogwarts,
you'll want to dive into
some of the local activities
like Quidditch.
To play this awesome game, you need
your own equipment.
A broom, some personal goggles,
and a pair of socks.
The rest is mostly covered
by Hogwarts.
Quidditch $550.
Wizards break a lot of things
in their time at Hogwarts.
Unfortunately, they break a lot
of expensive things.
Costs of damages $6,945,035.
And at the end of a long
stressful day of fighting evil,
you’re going to want to go
to the local pub and have
a delicious butter beer
with your friends.
One round of butter beer is $10.
To calculate the grand total,
we considered that you
spend seven years at Hogwarts
and the inflation value
the British pound changes
over those seven years.
So, converted into wizard money
then converted back into dollars
then factor in structural
macroeconomics, bank loan fees,
national fiscal policies,
you know stuff like that
and it gets us to $15,360,122.
If you want to afford it all,
better be friendly with those goblins
at Gringotts bank
or talk to J.K. Rowling.
She is loaded.